all right terminator dark fate is out is
it out i don't know when i'm going to
upload this
maybe i'll upload it before it's out no
probably not though this is
it's not really a spoiler talk it's just
me bitching about something for a few
minutes here point is if you have plans
on seeing terminator dark fate i'm gonna
have spoilers in here big spoilers you
might not want to watch this video but
if you're a fan of terminator 2
movie's just going to piss you off
anyway so whatever stick around if you
want all right spoiler alert done the
spoilers have been warned
so here we go first of all first things
first in my spoiler free review
i didn't give enough props to the actors
because you know the acting
the actors did fine i thought they did
good for what they had but my grievances
with this movie are not with the actors
it's with you know the writing the plot
blatant disregard for the legacy you
know the little things
and if i could compartmentalize my love
for terminator 2
and just look past the fact that they
[ __ ] shoot john
connor shotgun blast to the chest before
the titles even come up on this movie
before the beginning credits yet
maybe i could have a better time with it
but i can't because that's not how
people
are filmmakers out there if you just
want to [ __ ] kill legacy characters
because because you think you're george
rr martin or some [ __ ] go ahead do it
have fun
go nuts with your own characters and
your own properties in your own
franchise that you create meantime
you know what maybe don't [ __ ] kill
the rest of the characters people love
even if you want to move in a different
direction for the franchises people just
don't like that and yeah
you didn't hear me wrong john connor
actually all right credit where credit
is due the de-aging [ __ ] was amazing i
was like sarah connor john connor
granted they're dressed identical it's
like they were like change of clothes
[ __ ] that but it was young hot linda
hamilton well
john connor should have probably aged a
little more he looked like the same age
kids age a lot in those few years
in that phase of their life john connor
should have probably looked older but
whatever i digress
young john connor young younger sarah
connor they both look great and then
young arnold schwarzenegger out of
nowhere shotgun blast boom
kills john connor and he's just like all
right i'm gonna go walk on the beach now
walk on the beach
like a robot maybe i'll start a family
and it had all right you know at the
screenings
there the reps that put on the
screenings they have little clipboards
they want to take notes so like all
right so what did you think and i i
legit was like i'm gonna be honest with
you i do not know because i spent the
last two hours being [ __ ] pissed that
john connor took a shotgun blast to the
chest i don't even know how i feel about
the movie and
it's official movie just pissed me off
and now that i've had a day
to think about it well things have
fallen apart more it's not just that but
first i'm going to stick on john connor
for a bit
john connor just didn't have to die
why'd he have to die like why not
he did his part why not just have him
retire with jesse pinkman and alaska
maybe they're roommates now but
he doesn't have to die it's a big world
out there you can have other terminator
[ __ ] happen
and not kill the legacy character maybe
you can have your terminator movie and
then at the end have john connor and
sarah connor come in and be like all
right we're here for the sequel
you could have sarah connor and john
connor adult john connor come in and be
like hey all right well she was you
i was you we've all been you and now
we're here to protect you because
who am i kidding my entire life was
built for a war that never happened so i
never really got to live a normal life
so i'm going to spend my life
on the mission protecting you and that's
just if you look at the legacy character
angle really you can boil it down it's
much simpler than all that john connor
was a character we were rooting
for to live through terminator 2 because
something was trying to kill him when
you're rooting for a character to live
through a scenario like that you're not
rooting for them to live just without
one movie
then whatever happens after that one
movie it doesn't matter you're rooting
for them to live so they live on if they
don't live on
what's the point if you kill them in the
intro of the next movie it just feels
like a big [ __ ] you
right newt wait remember newt never
forget newt
james cameron apparently did though god
and if you're going to kill a legacy
character
you give them a hero's death like heroes
can die sure but
have them go out as them and have them
go out good
just shot like a punk by another some
rogue terminator because i guess skynet
just made it rain terminators that's
dumb
another breaking bad comparison actually
this is what it's like
imagine in the season premiere of better
call saul
in the season premieres of better call
saul at the very beginning it's him
running a cinnabon and just imagine this
one takes place
in a house in alaska and some guys kick
the door and shoot jesse pinkman oh i
guess he's dead now he didn't make it
out he doesn't get to live it's all for
nothing yeah does that sound stupid
i know i already saw it i was there with
john connor
in terminator dark fake and i guess that
happened because skynet sent
not one terminator not one t-1000 but
one terminator one t-1000
and a few more terminators that just
intermittently started springing up and
just started appearing through the
course of the last couple decades which
is the dumbest robot
[ __ ] brain ever like now skynet's a
[ __ ] why would you do that what
so skynet was like
all right one to take out sarah connor
if that fails
here we go backup plan this t-1000
advanced prototype which
it does say in t2 he's an advanced
prototype so i don't think they have a
hundred of these things i feel like it's
like oh we only got to make one all
right that's gonna be our killing
machine so i get that skynet didn't send
back a bunch of t1 thousands all right
that's fine the fact they sent a few of
anything back at
different times is stupid because it was
like all right
you know what in case the terminator
fails and the t-1000 fails we'll just
send back another terminator and another
terminator and another terminator and
another terminator i just i don't know
space it out what every few years
yeah yeah how many six six yeah six is
good tim burton's batman be sure to
space it out though
otherwise someone might not be able to
actually take them down
is skynet not able to control when and
where they show up yes skynet is
does it purposely dropped the terminator
off when sarah was younger when jon
wasn't born and it knew it was in los
angeles did it on purpose same with the
t-1000 skynet
and the resistance must be able to
control when and where they send someone
back through time because the resistance
sent kyle reese and the t-800 at the
exact day
and time skynet sent the terminators
back if they were off by like a day
sarah connor and or john connor would
have died so why wouldn't skynet be like
you know what
we are gonna send six of these things
back but at the same time
in the same place you imagine the log of
[ __ ]
kyle reese would have been made to eat
if he took on like
six of those things at the same time
there's no [ __ ] way
skynet would have lost john connor's
truly [ __ ] i mean obviously
the plan worked one of them got john
connor but no let's just space it out
every few years
among different locations whatever so
stupid in fact i'm gonna take another
sip of water no i'm out of water
i need a refill water refills on nice
oh yeah this is the kind of water i need
to talk about terminator dark fate
i mean you can make the argument that
they could have sent the t-1000 and the
terminator from terminator 1
to the terminator 1 timeline and just
got it all over with but is this simple
i just i'm
breaking the fourth wall i don't think
james cameron knew there was going to be
a sequel to terminator and i know
they didn't have the technology to make
t-1000 in the 80s there it is and then
this terminator kills john connor and
then the unexpected happens
he feels bad about it cause that's
totally how they work right
listen and understand
that terminator is out there
it can't be bargained with it can't be
reasoned with
it doesn't feel pity or remorse
or fear and it absolutely will not stop
ever until you are dead
and then after you're dead it might feel
bad about it
maybe even start a family look it's
weird
i know but that's how they're gonna
write movies in your future
what the [ __ ] is that [ __ ] i mean
granted arnold was funny in this movie i
mean he
he has one of my favorite lines in the
entire movie because he's like
talking interior decorating he's talking
about this guy i once knew a guy who was
gonna put mono colored curtains
in the baby's bedroom and i told him
don't do it it's [ __ ] funny like that
it made me laugh for sure it's also
just not really terminator it is funny
because he is a robot talking about
interior decorating because the limbic
response of laughter because something
is ironic
does not mean the movie's good and it
does not mean that things should even be
there it goes against
the terminate the terminator supposed to
be scary if you look at terminator 1
terminator is he's metal jason voorhees
he's scary terminator 2
worked because he was programmed as a
protector
not a destroyer and then they even
tweaked the chip and they were like all
right now you're a learning computer
well i mean theatrical cut is like
my cpus are known that process or
learning computer the more contacts i
have with humans
the more i learn that's a nice way of
just brushing over that
awesome scene if you haven't seen the
director's cut it's such a sweet scene
but they have to go into his brain and
take out the chip and then
flip a switch and it's like all right
now you can learn point is
after john connor died he's like i feel
bad now
so he starts a family and he's all nice
now which
the reason this piss that actually makes
me really oh yeah i don't like it
because
that means arnold didn't have to go down
in the lava in terminator 2.
remember what he said right there's
still one more chip
and it must be destroyed also and john
kondo's like no no
no stay with us you can be with us it'll
be all right he's like i'm sorry john
i'm sorry i don't know why you crying
something i could never do
when in reality now we know i'm sorry
john i'm sorry i gotta go
when in fact i don't actually have to go
we could live in a cabin in the woods
somewhere no one would really know
and it won't start skying it necessarily
in fact if i'm around
if skynet sent back any more terminators
i'll be there
to [ __ ] them up and then your mommy
doesn't have to cry over your dead body
she doesn't have to cry you'd all be
okay but you know what we're not gonna
do that
bye die horribly [ __ ] you in the end
that's just how i feel it's
it's an act that happened at the
beginning of the movie which was the
highest high followed by the lowest low
because
the beginning of the movie is sarah
connors that footage
you know the footage like they fly apart
like leaves and she's talking to dr
superman and i was like oh [ __ ] we are
back man oh my god this is taking it
back to terminator yes we are back yes
and now one minute later what the [ __ ]
is this [ __ ] it was like the highest
high followed by the lowest slowly
they use that to hook you with the
nostalgia and then be like all right we
just wanted you to feel
the loss when we take this bowie knife
and shove it right up your
[ __ ] tank it just killed me if it
didn't kill you great i'm glad i'm glad
you can enjoy the movie but it's just a
line it's a line i can't get over and
i'm sure if i was a good critic
i could have but i cannot because oh
i'm just a guy i'm a guy who talks
movies and i like them and when i like
them
i really like them when i love them i
love them even more
and i just hate it when people do stupid
[ __ ] that they don't have to do so those
are my thoughts those are my thoughts on
terminator
dark fate and a dark fate it was or it's
a terminator dark
fate have you seen it what did you think
about it did you leave a bad taste in
your mouth are you cool with it or
you're like hey you know what i can
compartmentalize and i had a fun time
with the movie are you like me where
you're like yeah it still ends at
terminator 2 i have terminator one and
two and
i'll enjoy those things whatever you
think comment below let me know also
september journal's coming
i was so late on it i was like i might
as well do it right before october
journal so it'll be like september
journal
and then not too long after that october
journal it'll be like
one week out hopefully i'm such a
procrastinator
anyhow september journal i'll try to
make it the next video after this one
so you got it and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
swapping hands [ __ ] i'm not even
punching
[Music]
you